coming up on 5 56 on your friday morning
you know the long-term future of the 95
and the 215 northern beltway might
include a big connection you got it
we're going
centennial bowling
so somewhere down the road probably
after the centennial ball is finished or
scheduled to finish in 2024 it is likely
that u.s 95 in the northwest valley is
also going to be known as
i-11
in the multi-layered world of getting a
project like this finalized one of the
things that has to happen is something
you may have heard of an environmental
impact statement except a new facebook
post from the nevada department of
transportation has a pretty big mouthful
that may not take as long to compete
complete the i-11 environmental impact
statement is now a p-e-l a planning and
environmental linkages study okay
the post goes on to explain that back in
january and on the federal highway
administration determined that a focused
pel study will achieve the same
objectives within a shorter time period
than a tier one eiis
now i haven't lost you because ndot does
want to hear what you think about where
i-11 is going to go through the valley
an online public information meeting
opens tuesday also several in-person
public meetings are planned we've got
links to those and links to all of our
centennial bowling stores on our website
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy the email is
traffic 8 8newsnow.com